My name is Axel Gern.
I'm head of autonomous driving here at
Mercedes Benz Research and Development in North America in Sunnyvale.
We started the group three years ago,
out of a team of seven people and we have grown it now up to six teams.
I'm really excited to work on that hot topic.
We have a very long tradition in autonomous driving at Mercedes-Benz.
We drove autonomously on the highway already 20 years ago during the Prometheus project.
The latest big achievement was driving
the historic world events route from Manhattan to Fordham in 2013,
showing that driving on country roads and inner city traffic is possible.
We introduced the stop-and-go assist in 2013,
which allows you to drive semi-autonomously in stop and go traffic.
And we recently launched the Drive Pilot,
which allows you to drive semi-autonomously on
highways. So we take autonomous driving very seriously,
and I think we have been really successful already in that field.
When hiring people for the autonomous driving team,
we're looking for strong computer science skills especially programming in C++.
In addition for prototypes,
we're using MATLAB and we are using Python for
scripting and deep learning tools perspective.
We are looking at a general good understanding
about autonomous driving and how that works.
And we are looking at the solid foundation in terms of math,
statistics, probabilistic and algorithms.
When preparing for the interview,
the applicants should brush up their programming skills.
Secondly, they should think about how their experience and education fits to the job.
Some applicants are surprised to hear questions,
how does an autonomous system works and then people should prepare that in advance,
should have an understanding
what's going on in that field.
And also, what Mercedes has already achieved in that field.
Personally, I want to see in the interview from
the applicant that he or she is interested,
motivated, curious about the topic,
wants to learn how it works.
At Mercedes, we have lots of interns and we are happy to
train people to get the right skills and get experience in the field.
We have employees from all around the world from China,
from India, from Germany,
from the US, from France,
from Spain, from actually all around the world.
I think, the nanodegree is a great thing to get the right experience in that field.
So if you have already a really solid foundation in computer science, for example,
and you have successfully achieved the nanodegree you are a pretty good candidate for this.
First of all, I love the topics of working on autonomous driving is terrific.
Probably, I have the best job in the world right now.
Working in Mercedes also is highly motivating
because we can bring autonomous cars to reality.
People are coming here because they are
motivated to work in the best project in the world I think.
They are keen to work on it.
They're focused on getting their job done and
explore new ways of solving this really challenging task of autonomous driving.
In terms of teamwork and the culture and the collaboration,
it's awesome in here.
So we have a highly motivated team working together to solve the problems.
It's also where I love to come to work every day.
If you want to shape the future for autonomous cars at Mercedes Benz, apply.